the joy I get the pleasures I got out of
writing on writing nonfiction writing
essays which is really what I do these
days in journalism is is mostly of
figuring out what I think you know I
wrote a piece about trying to figure out
what I think about the current nightmare
debacle of Iraq in terms of what US
policy should be and what the debate
should be and and that's such a you know
complicated just profoundly complicated
thing to figure out for me anyway that
it's only through writing and thinking
it through that I was able to to begin
to figure out what I really did think we
should or shouldn't do or how long or
when we should leave and all those
things so I find you know I sometimes
begin a piece like that with a basic
sense but I often find it is only
through the writing that I actually get
any clarity in my own mind for fiction
the pleasure the the joy is as being God
of my own little world and creating this
world and these characters in this
latest book in the night middle of the
19th century and and while as other
fiction writers have said they take on
their own life and surprise 1 the author
by doing things you didn't expect still
you are God and and and and so that's
hugely fun and since I'm relatively new
at it I've been dabbling I dabbled a
fiction before the last 11 years but
I've only been publishing then I still
feel like as I expect to feel for the
rest of my life that I'm still figuring
it out so that the joy of kind of if not
mastering at least having good moments
of figuring out how to do this this
thing that again because of my my
childhood and my parents sort of worship
of fiction great novels I feel as though
I you know it's if not the highest best
calling at least one of them and and and
when I feel as though I can I've gotten
a line rider a character right or a
paragraph or a chat
after I that feels pretty great uh the
any kind of writing nonfiction or
fiction it is a struggle it's a it's a
very you know moment to moment struggle
figuring out the the right word the
right sentence the right paragraph the
right page the right structure for the
larger thing and when you're writing a
book as my my two novels have been six
hundred odd pages that's that there's a
you know that becomes an enormous
structure to try to to try to get as
right as possible so that's it's a it's
a pleasurable struggle when you're done
but it's it is a struggle while it's
going on I actually find the work of
writing fiction less of a struggle less
of a stressful procedure than I do
writing a 1700 word essay that to me is
that the essay is or journalism really
is all is sort of is almost pure
struggle and then I'm only happy when
I'm done whereas fiction actually
writing fiction has moments of of
pleasure amid the struggle while it's
while I'm writing it on my creative
process depending it depends on what I'm
doing I mean there to the degree my life
now is is divided between working alone
in a room essentially writing fiction or
writing essays it's a matter of doing
whatever research is necessary and then
just being at home with all of whatever
fact there are notes thoughts stray
stray bits and letting that marinate and
tell I can figure out a way that looks
interesting or enlightening or
entertaining to to write a page so I I
don't have a but but it requires for me
it requires to do what I consider good
writing to be alone in a room for you
know a few hours at a time and then
whatever alchemy happens happens but
then the other half of my creative life
which is doing the studio three
sixties as was doing magazines editing
magazines in the past is this entirely
collaborative process tote entirely or
significantly and vastly different from
the creative process of writing which is
about finding a team of people with whom
you're comfortable but not identical and
being open to all of the various ideas
and approaches that that team brings and
and and if you're the leader of the team
trying to to inspire those people to do
good work and and and and and and keep a
vision of what it is you're trying to do
collaboratively so it's not just a
collection of ten people doing ten
different things but all fits into the
to the larger the larger vision and so
though as I say those are those are very
different i get satisfaction out of both
and and and very happy that i literally
my days are divided between those two
forms of creative process so you know by
the time i'm done doing a radio program
in all the meetings and conversations
and back and forth that requires i'm
very happy the next morning to go back
in my room and spend five hours alone